the hotel concierge held at gunpoint  with Kim Kardashian speaks on camera for  the first time Joshua screaming like  hell he is with Abdul Rahman in Paris  and we're discovering there so much more  to the robbery than the world knows for  weeks  speculation has run rampant that Kim's  heavy social media presence gave thieves  a reason to come after her diamonds  which are worth millions but Raman says  that was not why they broke in and the  guy was asking for the money or his  money money money you know I was wrong  we not run without all your friends you  know and at that moment I I think she  believed that they was there for her  wing I mean cause that's a it's a huge  ring for him it was just a ring I think  so he puts a ring in his pocket and then  what did he say boy he's the money money  money money money  yes I'm a cash tune into et Thursday to  hear his full first-hand account  including why he claims other  celebrities were targets to